[Musique]
ce lundi 25 juillet a été présenté et
signé un projet de développement de
structures hydraulique de l'île de
grande comore au conseil départemental
de la réunion ce projet fruit d'une
coopération entre le département et
l'agencé française de développement vise
à améliorer l'accès à une eau de bonne
qualité pour la population comorienne la
convention d'aidé financier il s'agit
d'une subvention de 425 mille euros qui
va permettre de financer des études
préalables à un projet déductions en eau
potable dans le nord-est de l'île de
grande comore et ils se
ce projet ce projet ce financement sera
mise en oeuvre par de l' expertise
technique réunionnaise développé par la
saphir et par l'office de l'eau
réunionnais et c2 expertise en
ingénierie
travailler dans le cadre d'une
coopération décentralisée entre le
département de la réunion et l'île
grande comore elle a aidé accompagne
financièrement cette coopération ce
projet s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
convention fille cole facilités de
financement des collectivités françaises
mis en place par l'afd un dispositif qui
permet aux collectivités territoriales
françaises d'accompagner des projets
dans les pays en développement
l'eau c'est la vie est parfois quand le
manque au robinet ou bien un manque dans
les champs agricoles et bien c'est toute
la production agricole qui en pâtit
c'est hop la vie familiale qui souffrent
de ce manque d'eau c'est pour cela que
nous allons porter notre expertise et
notre capacité d'accompagnement à nos
pays voisins de la zone notamment
comment et à terme je l'espère d'autres
pays qui pourraient nous solliciter pour
quoi le projet intègre aussi la
sensibilisation de la population aux
nouveaux usages de l'eau et la mise en
oeuvre d'un programme de travaux urgents
comme la création d'un plus violent et
la réhabilitation de réservoirs
existants
[Musique]